there are no starving artists anymore
they're not starving
they're getting salaries of over a
quarter million dollars a year if
they're any good because they can tell
the story
and digitize the service or product
online and entice
customer acquisition the business travel
component while everybody's so
up you know optimistic about it i don't
see it coming back and a lot of it will
but not a hundred percent
hey everyone welcome back to the meet
kevin show today meet kevin
meets kevin o'leary investor
entrepreneur of course
mr wonderful i am super excited to ask a
ton of questions about what the heck is
going on in this crazy market and world
please welcome kevin o'leary hey kevin
how's it going
great to be here kevin i love this kevin
squared thing it's great
i love that absolutely so kevin i want
to get right into it
we had cpi data this morning it wasn't
as bad as expected what's your take on
inflation
is the fed going to lose control are
they going to maintain control what's
your take
i think the fed's been pretty clear they
are focused pedal to the metal and
keeping rates at basically zero until
they can get these last
nine million people replaced in the
economy
redeployed and and i think everybody's
beginning to realize
it's happening very quickly that the
economy that we're trying to stimulate
back
doesn't resemble 2019 or 2020 anymore
there's been this incredible
digitization that's occurred during the
pandemic
where now the entire economy and and
purchase preferences as well with
individuals has changed it's very much
direct to consumer
all kinds of new business models have
emerged retailers taking a back seat in
terms of how products are sold to people
now
all kinds of fundamental changes going
on in business travel
what's happening in terms of
expenditures in the s p 500 companies
right down to
small you know montpar businesses and we
and
we don't yet know what it looks like
until we get out of this pandemic so as
far as the fed's concerned
they're focusing on all the people that
lost their jobs
for example in business travel and
airlines that's 10 percent of the
employed people somehow involved in that
chain
in america all the people that lost
their jobs in movie theaters that were
cineplexes that nobody wants to go back
to anymore
all the people that lost their jobs in
restaurants and food services businesses
have to be redeployed by the new digital
economy whatever that looks like
and that's why you're going to have a
current focus on that for at least the
rest of the year
and that's extremely constructive for
stocks i mean we've never
seen anything like this i have never
ever
seen data like what i'm seeing now in q4
of this year we may achieve past the
nine percent gdp growth
you haven't seen that since the 1950s
kali yeah it's absolutely incredible
just the growth of projections i believe
they're
they're thinking if we add together 2021
and 2022 we could be growing like we
were growing in o5 which
a lot of folks don't want to hear 05
because what came after that
which begs the question is it possible
that if the fed
keeps keeps the fed funds rate so low
for so long that we end up letting the
inflation genie out of the bottle i mean
i've heard you yourself say hey we
we shouldn't be spending all this money
yeah i think a lot of the expenditures
wasted um that's because it's such a
blunt instrument the 1.9 trillion dollar
package that already has been legislated
i would say 50 of that will be wasted
the infrastructure package is more
interested
interesting but we don't yet know what
that's going to look like and it may
have the detrimental
impact of raising corporate taxes again
which makes the u.s uncompetitive
the idea that yellen can run around the
world asking for a standard minimum
corporate tax is a joke that's never
going to happen
the asian markets which are very very
tax efficient in terms of low taxes
are killing us in growth they're just
really getting competitive
and they have no interest in raising
corporate taxes you know to kill that
golden goose so we will
again if this tax proposal is put
through be the highest corporate tax
jurisdiction in the world in terms of
the g7
and you'll start to see all the
inversions starting again companies
making moves to get out of the u.s
so i'm not sure they're going to be able
to do that easily so that's a big
question mark
regarding inflation you have a
bellwether every day you simply watch
the 10-year
the 10-year bond will not be competition
for equities until it has a
handle in front of it which is a long
time from now we're about 1.6
so you're going to stay the course on
stocks because that stocks actually do
well in inflationary times
they tend to actually have pricing power
and corporations do very very well when
inflation comes into the economy it's
runaway inflation you don't want you
don't want to turn america into
venezuela or cuba or something like that
but i think we're a long way from that
right now long way from runaway
inflation that's and that's a fear that
a lot of folks have is that
we might see that kind of hyperinflation
that we're going to
that that essentially the country is
debasing the dollar
and and that we can't trust the dollar
anymore and that's maybe why you see a
run into
cryptocurrencies is that not something
that you believe that the dollar could
could lose its value or potentially even
collapse or
lose its status as uh the world's uh you
know reserve currency
well there's some speculation you saw a
lot of pundits talking about this this
week that china was really trying to
promote cryptocurrencies as a way
to getting out of under the matter of
the dollar because the truth is the
chinese economy is based on the us
dollar
in the sense that everything outside of
their economy settles in usd
nobody wants to take the chinese one and
hold that long term they have no idea
what the policy makers are going to do
with it so if you want to do business
out of hong kong or out of china you
asked to settle in us dollars
and that's really what the chinese are
frustrated about what they prefer to see
is a cryptocurrency
perhaps one they bring on them on
themselves uh which i would never take
into custody
because the chinese could simply turn it
off if they weren't happy with you or
something you said about them
or bitcoin and that's why bitcoin is at
a new high today
no government controls it but it does
have its own issues emerging now so
we've got a very interesting time going
on here we're basically
and i think the best way to put it in an
economic war with china
china doesn't play by the rules doesn't
give us access to their courts does not
give us access to the middle class they
use american courts to litigate their
own ip domestically
and sell tons of products into the
largest economy on the earth currently
which is the us economy
and until that playing field is leveled
we're going to have tremendous tension
with that regime
this morning came out and said that they
want to play nice with biden in so many
words
it sounds like you don't believe them no
i don't
i just look at the last 10
administrations and how crafty they are
in making nice sounding nice and then
keeping everything the same as before
the only thing the chinese understand
and respect
is the stick that's what they understand
and so you can look and back
for the last five administrations and
realize until the last one where they
really put the pressure on them
nothing was changing the idea that you
can form a cohort
of american and european economies
to work together to bring the chinese
a bit to bay is not going to happen
because
in europe basically 25 of most of those
economies
is tied to china so while they'll give
lip service they don't want in any way
take their relationship with a quarter
of their gdp
that's why it never worked the only time
now
is to go hard core against china and say
look we understand we're in a
competition
we understand the living you know the
the
playing field is not level so let's
let's level it and the way to level it
is to say let's
let's make it level right now what would
that mean delist all the chinese stocks
do not give them access to our courts we
don't get access to their courts
make it the same for both then build it
back up when the chinese feel the
pressure of that stick
they'll understand they have to somehow
raise the bar
now that sounds torturous and difficult
but it has to be done
it has to be done it makes no sense to
me that an american manufacturer has to
give up their ip
basically have it stolen that hasn't
changed you've heard a lot about it from
the last administration but it's the
same
the chinese people are not at fault it's
the
policy of the chinese government that is
causing these tensions
and it's really time to address it now
now now's the time because if they
become bigger which they will in the
next 20 years
you won't have that leverage anymore
remember the stick
is what they appreciate the stick is
what they want the stick is what will
work
the stick is what they want i mean the
stick is generally associated with
sanctions i i don't believe that china
wants sanctions
but it sounds like that's what you're
advocating no i'm just beyond sanctions
i want to take them right out of the
financial system in north america
they don't get access to it it's that
simple alibaba
neo expand d-list sure you know the
economy the economy is so
large and there's so many other places
to deploy capital
in those markets it'll find a way or if
you insist you can simply go buy those
shares
on the hong kong exchange or whatever
exchange it is but it'll make it much
harder for compliant institutions in the
us to do business with them
and also you know frankly that stick
will really put some pressure on them to
solve the problem
my assumption is you have a few rough
quarters when you do this you implement
it
but then we get to what we want a really
collateral discussion with them about
leveling the playing field
america can compete china can compete
just level the playing field and let the
competition begin
but don't keep it in this unbalanced
football field where it's so unfair
for other economies that don't get
access to the chinese economy if they
want to play with the big boys
they've got to play with a level playing
field and if it takes a little pressure
to get them there
that's okay the stick works
now what do you think about uh tesla
tesla's one of the first manufacturers
in china us manufacturers in china
many ownership uh in in their company uh
to china
do you think that this maybe sets a
precedent for maybe there is a
nice way to play with china maybe we
just got to do the elon musk way
yeah absolutely i mean that is a right
direction to go into partnership to
actually have access to their
middle class and sell cars to them why
not elon musk is a is a maverick in
terms of what he does he doesn't play by
the rules obviously
but he's actually a good way a good
designer
of how this relationship should work if
american companies if boeing wanted to
go to china and build planes there they
shouldn't have to give up control of
their ip to do that
and that would help the that would help
the chinese economy if you know
think about all the technology they can
actually provide for that growing
economy
and in partnership way i don't know why
they're not discussing that but that's
the kind of potential that we could have
across all kinds of different
technologies and also when it comes to
pandemics
you really have to ask yourself why do
so many of these originate in china i'm
not
pointing fingers i'm just saying if
we're more cooperative on biotechnology
we could stop them in their tracks and
save billions of dollars
millions of lives and be cooperative
that basis
again the stick is the way to go
do you believe that the biden
administration will change anything over
the next four to eight years
i think the byte administration is
focusing on what they said
in terms of their mandate to get every
american vaccinated that wants the
vaccine and we're in the throes of that
we're probably in the sixth inning
they've done very well in their in
execution of a bit of a setback today on
the j
j vaccine but that doesn't mean we can't
keep going we've still got two other
alternatives american
ingenuity and technology brought these
new medicines
out of moderna and pfizer and that's
tremendous but at the end of the day
that's the focus of the administration
when that's over with then the
infrastructure package comes and
somewhere along the line he's going to
have to address china
now i'm glad to see he did not take off
the tariffs that were put on and hard
won from the last administration like
them or not like them the policy was
very very good for the american economy
to start pushing back on china but i
think he can use that and continue to
lever it
but you know at the end of the day the
chinese are very very good at playing
wanted
administration off against the other
because their leadership is for life
that's not how the american economy
works you get these four to eight year
cycles and they've learned how to play
that ball
they'll immediately say let's have a
meeting let's get together let's talk
about our future together as friends
and nothing will happen you gotta go to
that meeting
with a stick wow wow uh so i want to go
back to something you mentioned earlier
was uh
this digitization of our economy there
are a lot of folks
very excited about investing in recovery
stocks which obviously have done
phenomenally since
the election uh the recovery of even the
macy's the nordstroms
uh and uh the airlines what's your take
i mean is this a sector that you stay
away from is it a value trap like kathy
woods says what's your take
no um these are not uh stay-at-home
stocks anymore these are work from
anywhere stocks
and so what you're starting to see
happen up and down the s p 500 is that
companies are realizing people that work
in accounting
compliance or logistics who used to work
in cubicles at
hq do not want to return to those
cubicles anymore and that represents
about 15
of the workforce they're asking for more
flexibility in lifestyle maybe they're
raising elderly parents maybe they're
raising children
they don't want to do the commute but
whatever reason it is we now have proven
technology
that allows them to work efficiently and
productively from their homes
and so you're going to start to see
these stocks become the bellwethers of
the new generation of digitization
they're the ones that have allowed a
global you know move
to e-commerce and it's not just
domestically zoom for example
crowdstrike docusign adobe microsoft
licenses
shopify these are all the tools that are
used to digitize america whether you're
nike or whether you're a small business
around the corner
and companies like facebook allow for
geo locked advertising there's so much
of this technology that was put to work
over the last year
that's proven to be very very productive
and in a way will change the cost
structure of the american economy to the
positive give you an example
you don't have to fly to bentonville
anymore and spend two days to meet the
buyer at walmart the world's largest
retailer you can do it on a zoom call
get 18 minutes and the buyer themselves
are 20 or 30
more productive and you save thousands
of dollars in business travel now it's
not good news for the airlines because
even though they're coming back it's all
basically vacation tickets
so 248 dollars was the average ticket
last week including the return travel
that means everybody's going to
disneyland in a big tube
that's a very crappy business they won't
make any money and as a result of that
those airlines
over the next two years probably a
couple of them have to go bankrupt
and consolidate capacity because
business travel is permanently impaired
by maybe 15 20 percent
but there's nothing wrong with airlines
going bankrupt they're very good at it
they do it every 10 years
and they reduce capacity and that's what
the fed is worried about
all the people are displaced we're
highly trained employees we've got to
find a way to redeploy them
maybe it's going to be cloud kitchens
maybe it's going to be pick and pack
storage maybe it's going to be
all kinds of new digital reasons to
exist
in the new digitized america 2.0 but
we've got to find them jobs
wow wow so uh of of airlines that could
go bankrupt any particular ones you look
at or you're looking at the most highly
leveraged ones or
do you think a company like spirit could
be the one that wins because they don't
cater so much to business and they cater
more towards the disneyland traveler
well all the balance sheets are upside
down and a combination of loans from the
government and debt they went and raised
on their own in the open markets the fed
kept the debt markets liquid
so the deterioration of even one of the
strongest companies in the airline
industry boeing
that balance sheet has been decimated
there's billions and billions and
billions of dollars of debt on it
now i'm not saying boeing will suffer
the slings and hours of the operators
because they're one of the companies in
the world that makes airlines and we do
need them
but the airline industry itself is gone
through a
massive change really it's just a bus
now a bus to move people around to their
vacation destinations the business
travel component while everybody's so up
you know
optimistic about it i don't see it
coming back a lot of it will but not a
hundred percent
and that fifteen twenty percent was
where all the profit was when you paid
you know five
thousand dollars for a trip to europe on
a business class or
first-class seat nobody needs to do that
anymore so you go there for a vacation
and you do it for 999 dollars the
airline makes virtually no money doing
that
they're just filling up tubes it's a
miserable business but that's okay
you know you've got 11 sectors on the
economy you don't have to focus on the
losers
you can focus on the winners and and the
winners sound
like you had mentioned sound like the
adobes the facebooks the microsoft's huh
yeah i think technology is a good bet
and will be it's got volatility but
people say to me oh it's over for the
you know the zoom stocks and the
shopifys no it isn't
it's in they're in their second inning
it's hilarious if you look at the
volatility
of uh of amazon over the last 20 years
you would have never owned it it's so
volatile some years it goes down 38
but in the long run it's created a
trillion dollars worth of value for
shareholders same thing is going to
happen to these
these economies and these stocks that
are going to provide digitization
another sector which i really believe in
now is healthcare i think we're going to
domesticate all of drug manufacturing
hazmat materials medical devices
to puerto rico to canada to mexico to
north america
so that we're not be held into the
chinese when it comes to a pandemic
because we don't know what covet 20 21
and 22 are or when they're going to come
but there will come there's no question
about it and we need to be ready for
that and
obviously use our technology to protect
us in a way we hadn't thought of before
so that's another one and the consumer
whenever you tr you sprinkle
1.9 trillion free dollars out of a
helicopter just throw it down at people
for free
the consumer spends it so i think
they're going to be very very strong in
the next year year and a half so i like
those sectors over
let's say energy or airlines or anything
else frankly
got it now biden you know of localizing
production
that's a big priority of biden for
example even with auto manufacturing
wants to use
american unions to to build vehicles in
america
what's the possibility though that using
american labor just ends up
shooting prices sky-high and then people
have to default to chinese or
japanese-made vehicles yeah that is a
big problem biden is in a bit of a
pressure squeeze on that one
you know it's great um the only way to
make the american economy
uh self-reliant sustainable long-term
is to make the economy competitive
globally so that all
people that want to invest in
corporations from all countries and all
jurisdictions come to america like they
do
to vietnam like they did to china like
they do to asia and singapore
because those economies are very
productive very low taxes
extremely high growth and have very good
domestic markets as well
so the problem he's got is you know the
rhetoric from the left side of his party
to tax the rich and take all the money
away from people and
d you know disincentivize
entrepreneurship in america is not a
good model
because that's not going to get people
saying gee i can't wait to invest in
america the highest corporate tax rate
in the world
that's just not going to happen and so i
think that debate even within his own
party is going to be very tough
now what happens because i'm a bit of a
policy wonk midterm elections are a bit
of a problem for biden because
every incumbent every incumbent
regardless of party
loses seats in in the midterm it just
happens that way
so he's on this really delicate razor
wire balance given that he's sort of got
you know the ability to do this if every
one of his party members agrees
and that means he has to get it jammed
through in less than 24 months i don't
think it's gonna be that easy
i think it's going to be hard fought i
think he's going to lose seats he
probably knows it so it's better to come
in with a more
moderate middle of the road strategy and
leave the massive tax hikes
for afterwards you know at some point
after the economy is running at full
throttle back to unemployment under four
percent
like it was part of the pandemic and i
think that's a ways off so i think
you've got a really interesting
political
scenario coming but if all of a sudden
he jams up corporate tax rate to global
highs
the economy just sputters out that's
what will happen wow
tell me about this so you actually think
despite us stimulating as much as we are
just that corporate tax increase could
be enough to to sputter out the economy
could you define that a little bit what
are you saying sure it's a very simple
equation you're pouring free money
out of the sky from a helicopter into
into anywhere you can stuff it
okay but then you're raising taxes so
you're taking it back
right away before it doesn't have a
chance to have any effect whatsoever
you're asking people to pay more tax and
corporations to pay more tax
what was the point of the free money
then i mean
that made no sense you're basically
letting it fall out of the helicopter
and immediately the tax man grabs it
it's before it does anything so that
that really makes you can't suck and
blow at the same time it doesn't make
any sense
and that's really the bottom line that's
the problem he's got
because corporations uh don't have
feelings they don't have emotions they
can move
overnight people tend not to want to
leave their families
so maybe the u.s has to start
considering what the europeans did a
value-added tax that taxes usage
but doesn't tax necessarily corporations
frankly in some ways
the nordic model works better the swiss
model where there's basically no
corporate tax they just tax people
and so much competition for capital goes
into those countries
to set up businesses to service you know
europe and asia from countries with no
corp or low corporate taxes
and that the people pay the vit tax i
think there'll be a lot of dialogue
about this but just raising corporate
taxes
is going to be very detrimental yeah it
does sound like in order for biden to
even get his 50 votes it
does sound like he'll probably have to
compromise down to like a 24 or 25
percent
if if he ends up going for that
corporate tax bush do you think if he
goes for it there'll be some kind of
compromise or
where's your take on that i think he's a
good president for the times in the
sense that he seems to want to be more
of the
i mean america could use a boring
president for a while it was it was just
too exciting with the last
administration
but i'm not but i'm not being critical
their policies were right on and so
you know i think biden now is trying to
be the oldest
the old style um leader where he where
he believes in compromise on both sides
now i don't think the country is in that
mood anymore you've got some very very
divisive policies on either side of the
aisle
it may be very hard to get that love and
feeling back
and i'm not sure it'll happen you'll get
some indication of it in the midterms
which aren't that far away
but there's a lot of seats up for grab
there's a lot of um
aggressive tone in both parties and
you know in biden's case he's got to try
and stay a moderate
even though he's got some very very
aggressive almost
socialist pressures coming at him and
the same for the republicans who have
some extreme right-wing views that
they've got to somehow consolidate
so i think politics is getting really
interesting
yeah i want to go back to something you
mentioned about uh
airlines and hiring people and getting
back to this max employment
i got to thinking what happens when
you get even the tech firms who have
laid off tens of thousands of
individuals during the pandemic
what happens when they go to rehire but
let's say they laid off 20
000 they go back and just rehire the
best 5 000
right and now like you mentioned they
don't have to travel anymore so we need
less people traveling we need less sales
people because one person can do the
work on zoom
that five people did before in sales
what happens to all of those other
people and is that
is that just really good for the tech
companies for the bottom line
uh and what happens to all those people
where do they go it's a great question
but it goes back to the old analogy
that's used so often
everybody thought television would
destroy radio and radio is bigger than
it's ever been
and so what happens is the economy
evolves and creates new jobs and i'll
give you an example
well i do a lot of guest lecturing to
graduating cohorts of engineers
because generally a third of those
classes i don't care whether you're
mechanical robotic chemical whatever are
going to start companies and i like to
be
there for them as an investor and what i
find that's so intriguing
is i used to say look if you're going to
get yourself 180 000 in debt
in college for a graduate and
postgraduate degree pick a discipline
that's going to let you pay it back and
the top three are
engineering engineering and engineering
and if you have
you have any time at night take some
engineering classes that's what i used
to say
i don't say that anymore because in my
own portfolio of over
35 companies i look at my number one
growth
expense in the last 18 months has been
hiring
artists writers videographers
animators all of the people that have
digitized the websites of all of these
different companies
and they're they used to be dirt cheap
there are no starving artists anymore
they're not starving they're getting
salaries of over a quarter million
dollars a year if they're any good
because they can tell the story
and digitize the service or product
online and entice
customer acquisition and so there's a
whole new dynamic to the economy
that we never could foresee so i'm not
worried about good
good employees will get hired in a
growing economy
you just don't want to kill the golden
goose and the way you kill it is you
over tax it
wow so what do you say to people who
maybe have lost their jobs uh is is it a
matter of retooling and reskilling is it
a matter of
of uh waiting for that unemployment to
run out what do you say to folks
it really makes a lot of sense to go
back to what you were good at
when you were younger let's say you're
in your 40s you've lost your job if you
actually were a good writer
a photographer videographer editor those
are skills that are highly valued by
this digital economy and so
it's a retraining exercise there's lots
of online courses
that show you actually how to use fake
facebook
instagram um you know linkedin so you
can become an added value to a company
that's trying to use those platforms
and so i always say to people look if
you if you don't know how to use social
media train it
train on it so that you can show others
how to do it people will pay you
to help them build up traffic on their
website this sounds like such a basic
thesis but it's so true today yeah
yeah what's your take on universal basic
income is that's
going to be something that we need as
sort of this wealth gap continues to
widen
i don't think it works i think we have a
form of it right now with stimulus
checks flying in from the sky even to
people that are employed that really
never made any sense to me
it would have been better to give those
dollars to people that were actually
unemployed for longer while they found
new work
but you know that's a very blunt
instrument that's just another form of
taxation
i don't think it works i think a social
net can be there's different models you
can see what
the nordics do the swiss
um they they do provide a social net
uh for people that are you know poor
people in the lower class so they don't
suffer that's very important
but the idea that uh you have it's
almost
worth reading anne rand you know atlas
shrugged where you get this idea of can
you get half the economy to pay for the
other half in perpetuity
probably not um and and that's
you know there's a lot i haven't found a
country where that's been successful
long term
you know the soviet union collapsed cuba
i wouldn't want to live there venezuela
no thanks and they attempt that kind of
thing it just doesn't work
wow wow gotcha yeah so
in on the note of the wealth gap there's
a big uh
crisis essentially happening in real
estate where real estate is becoming
increasingly unaffordable and it seems
to be the competition of
the haves versus the haves and hearts uh
i know you have some uh
you know pretty pretty uh strong
arguments about commercial real estate
and transformations there
i want to start though with residential
what do people do do people buy a house
today do they
or do they just invest in stocks and
forget about real estate
well real estate falls into two large
asset classes and i've been
participating in both for a long time
commercial real estate is nowhere near
as safe and buoyant as residential
obviously if you've got companies saying
that fifteen 15 of their staff
are going to work from home that favors
residential real estate way over
commercial because if you had a
office tower in boston and all of a
sudden i'm seeing this happen every day
my lawyers are
are going to be cutting out 33 of their
floor space and
you know out of their out of their
corporate headquarters because a lot of
their staff don't want to return to the
office anymore
and so that puts pressure on the value
of triple a office
so let's say it was trading at a 4.2 cap
which is basically 4.2 percent yield
um i think uh by the time this is all
over
it'll be trading at a six percent cap a
six percent yield because there's going
to be it'll be harder to find tenants
that want to take long-term leases
and that's a lot of loss of value so
i've reduced my exposure to
commercial real estate from 31 percent
of my portfolio down to eight
and i've increased my holdings in
residential because i see
for the next two years a continued
buoyancy in in housing pricing the
ability to buy homes and rent them
most people in america want to live and
work
at home if they could and you know
it's not 24 7 there but they'd like the
ability to stay home a few days a week
and work you know and maybe go into the
office once a week or once a month or
once a quarter whatever it is that
flexibility
is what's pushing the value of
residential real estate up
i do not see that trend ending it also
gives
new geographies you know if you don't
want to live in san francisco and you
want to live in seattle but your main
job is in san francisco
you can do that now there's ways to do
that and you know maybe you travel
quarterly just to hq or
you know basically that kind of
flexibility and even my own organization
my holding company most of my staff
have indicated they have no interest in
going back nine to five to the office
anymore
we've proven over the last year we can
work independently and very successfully
and we're making that change now
you went from 31 commercial to 8 because
you and you see cap rates going up so
the risk premiums going up
why not go to zero well unfortunately
real estate has one attribute that has
never changed it's
relatively illiquid people it's not like
a stock you can buy and sell during the
day
real estate has very large transaction
costs associated with it
sometimes the building may be in
construction and has not been stabilized
for example that's one reason you
wouldn't sell it because it's a
diminished value
there's all kinds of reasons it's hard
to get to zero because there just isn't
enough liquidity
and also different asset classes have to
be treated differently i mean a hotel
in boston may be more valuable than an
office space because there's not a lot
of hotel
square footage right now there so i look
at it that way i've got a great team
that manages my real estate portfolio
we've determined that you know we're at
a point now where there's no there's no
reason to sell the last eight percent
we're going to wait 36 months and see
what happens
but that's a significant reduction in
exposure
and now i have a very very large cash
position to redeploy
we try on on average distribute six
percent from our operating company a
year
so that i'm really challenged i can't
use fixed income to get six percent
without taking inordinate risk
so it really favors uh the work i'm
doing in equities
and finding uh companies private
companies where i can take significant
positions in
um and that are cash flow positive and
that's
you know why i do what i do uh making
six percent you're in you're out
may sound easy but it's not right right
absolutely
now what do you believe that uh there's
going to be an opportunity to rope
rotate back into commercial do you want
to be a part of that i've heard you talk
about maybe a a transition of shopping
malls into
uh i think you mentioned this rumor that
shopping malls might turn into offices
uh because people don't want to go into
elevators anymore
it's not a rumor that's starting to
happen they have ample parking um
you are on a single floor and you can
set up offices in 200 square foot
shops that you know used to be retail
i'll give you an example of my thinking
on it let's think about
one of my big customers for my for my
consumer goods companies bed bath and
beyond
they closed 200 stores last year 200 and
they were so the anchor tenants of many
many b grade malls across america
they have no interest in using those
again because their online direct to
consumer sales are up 76
so their business remains intact they
curate consumer goods
oils scents candles sheets towels you
name it
it's a very successful model and brand
in that respect
but they don't need those stores and so
what's going to happen to those stores
the most likely outcome would be let's
say they traded at a
five cap before when they were fully
utilized fully stabilized and the tenant
was bed bath and beyond
now they're empty maybe somebody comes
along and says for two million dollars a
building i can turn it into
a cloud kitchen for all of the local
food delivery services or i can turn it
into a climate controlled pick and pack
facility for an online retailer or i can
turn it into residential condos
but it's going to require capital and so
the cap rate probably goes up to seven
seven and a half percent while plans to
to redeploy capital
switch it out to something profitable
again that's a time when i probably get
involved so i might go to the debt side
provide
construction financing or modification
financing
i think i could probably get nine ten
percent for that maybe maybe it's less
we'll have to see how much demand there
is
or i may um you know uh decide to take
an equity position in a company that
does that kind of conversion who knows
but
those are the kind of things my team is
looking at now
makes sense it also sounds like you
probably wouldn't want to be uh
spearheading any of those kind of
renovations
dealing with the cities huh no no i
think what's going to occur is because a
climate controlled pick and pack
facility uh or storage facility
employs very few people and is highly
profitable
but it doesn't employ anybody you can
run a giant facility
of climate control storage with 12
people instead of
1200 and so i think the politicians
there will not
favor that kind of conversion and not
allow building permits so i think it's a
very
long drawn out arduous difficult
conversion cycle
and frankly i find many other
opportunities more interesting
right now than going through all that
because i've been involved in that
business for decades
and so you know construction financing
permits local politicians yadda yadda
at some point you tire from that and you
want something that's a little more
productive
yeah no kidding uh gamestop this is uh
something very similar
what are your what are your thoughts on
gamestop is is it going to a thousand or
is it going to zero
well you know gamestop went through as
everybody knows a really interesting um
iteration it its brand as a result of
what occurred over the last five months
is worldwide the ip of gamestop the
actual brand itself
has way more value today than it had
five months ago before it became in
every
you know became part of every headline
around the world day after day
as you know the vigilantes or the reddit
crowd or the robin hood crowd whatever
you want to call it the democratization
of stock trading
so you recently saw they're going out to
raise capital
the analogy is netflix i guess
saw the writing on the wall when they
were mailing cds to everybody
and said we're going to digitize this
and they had a brand
maybe gamestop can do the same thing
maybe they can provide added
services they've got all these retail
locations maybe they can have
you know classes in a setting where
people want to spend time with each
other in those stores 1200 square feet
1700 of them
i don't know what the outcome will be
but if i was short that stock right now
i'd be worried and i'm not sure
and then because i think it's i think
it's going to get a second
uh kick at life i think that some very
smart people
probably see what i see in the ip being
worth something and this whole
social co you know constituency
supporting it
the pricing of the stock is kind of
irrelevant at this point but if you're
short
if you're short you're really hurting
yeah yeah no kidding
no kidding yeah just because the long
run hasn't really been priced in yet
because we don't really know
uh and the upside is uh is is limitless
so um i want to if they go back for a
moment
to somebody just starting out let's say
they've gone
20 30 000 do they try to buy
a one-bedroom house or condo or do they
go
all in on index funds or ishares
or uh you know do they just yolo it all
into tesla
what's what's your take there well i
have a rule that my mother taught me
decades ago that served me well in all
the volatility i experienced as an
investor from my early 20s on
a simple rule let's talk about the
market first never let one stock become
more than five percent of your portfolio
and never let a sector of which there
are 11 sectors
in the american economy like you know
real estate's now a sector
technology uh health care they're all
sectors never let the sector become more
than 20
of the portfolio and that gives you
diversification which is very important
to
to be able to survive volatility in a
market when you make a big bet and you
let tesla become 80 percent of your net
worth
and should should it correct a lot of
people
learned that the hard way in the dot-com
era um you know they had stocks like
pets.com that went to zero that kind of
thing
but if you have diversification um you
don't have that problem because the
likelihood that everything goes to zero
is lower
much lower regarding housing you have to
understand something about housing
you really can't buy a house for twenty
five thousand dollars so what it means
is that you're going to take on debt
and so mortgages are most people's
largest
obligation in their lives and their
largest asset is their home
there are periods in time when prices of
housing correct and you're under water
in other words you don't have any equity
anymore because you owe more
than the house is worth and so sometimes
the best thing to do is to say i'm going
to be a renter
until i can actually afford a mortgage
even if the market corrects
and that may be a better discipline
because the truth about retirement if
you have the average salary in america
56
000 it might be better to simply put
aside a hundred dollars a week put it
into an etf an index etf
the market has given over a long over
100 period
100 year period somewhere between six
and a half and nine percent return
on average long term some years are down
some years are up there is volatility
but the point is at the end of the day
that has ended up being the way you
retire with over a million and a half
dollars but you have to have the
discipline
of putting aside a hundred dollars a
week and there's so many different apps
you can use to do this now it's not like
it's hard to do
what's hard to do is change your
behavior because most people spend
everything they make and more
and then they end up in debt but it
would really be
you got to remember something when you
put 100 into an index fund that's in
your name
that money's for you it's not for
anybody else you're building your own
future which i think is a good way to
look at it yeah well
a big thing that we hear a lot about
right now is this
having an emergency fund having that six
month emergency fund
something that i found is a lot of
people they'll save up that cash they'll
build up that six month emergency fund
but before you know it vacation time
comes up and oh we'll just borrow from
the emergency fund and we'll just repay
it because
i mean whatever we'd like why not you
know and then what happens is
nobody ends up ever investing uh what's
i mean is a hundred bucks a week gonna
do it
it's the minimum if you can put 400
bucks aside which is actually doable
with your average salary of 56
000 it's the minimum obviously you
should do more simple way to look at it
is take ten percent of your paycheck
and put that away and never hit it do
not touch it
obviously i understand medical
emergencies and everything else but the
truth is
when you take money and burn it on a
vacation or buy some useless piece of
crap you're
never going to use which many people are
guilty of including me
you've actually you've killed off your
future that's money's not working for
you anymore
so do you really need another pair of
jeans another pair of shoes just look at
your closet of all the crap you don't
wear
that's all money you wasted the truth is
most people wear
you know maybe a dozen different things
they have even though they have 30 of
something
that's what my mother taught me she said
buy few things but buy really good
things when you buy them
that last and i that's the philosophy i
have in everything from watches to
clothing
if you like that video waiting you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe